my girl's fun though she likes to do
stuff in public that's cool although get
you into some weird scenarios one time
we were at a grocery store she stuck her
butt out in the aisle and I spanked it
and the six-year-old kid runs up and he
goes what'd she
do I was like what do you mean he's like
is she a bad girl I'm like she's a bad
girl all right that's when I realized me
and this kid are saying the exact same
thing but having a completely different
conversation he's like is she naughty
I'm like oh she's naughty he's like do
she have a lot of toys I'm like her
bedroom's full of toys he's like you
should do what my parents do to me when
I'm in trouble I'm like what's that you
should use her toys in front of her I'm
like damn maybe I
will wow this kid's
filthy